un supermarché ans à lille qui a
entrepris une initiative pour favoriser
des rencontres amoureuses
c'est complètement fou je vous le dis et
je voulais vous donner l'info à lille un
supermarché a mis en place un système
regarder pour pouvoir rencontrer l'amour
grâce à la couleur de votre panis est
pas fou ah oui ça franchement voilà ce
magnifique vachement bien c'est
vachement moins entre deux paquets de
riz trouvé ça absurde pourtant c'est bel
et bien la réalité un osé prendre un
panier vert si vous voulez trouver l'âme
soeur
j'ai eu un beau défi ça arrive à moi
j'adore sans une fois on voit les gens
en vrai pour les rencontrer on ne sait
pas avoir par les photos sur internet
et puis enfin réalité tu vois pas ce que
et en plus tu vois ce qu'ils agents son
panier c'est parce que le vieil adage
dis moi ce que tu as dans ton panier je
te dirai qui tu es si vous voyez que le
gabon voilà il a que des préservatifs
vous dites attention
bono a baissé bon bah disons le gabon
voilà je n'en veux pas s'il ya des
couches on n'y va pas non plus bien sûr
et saab serait d'écouter ou qu'il est
très vieux pour nous la main au panier
ça prend tout son sens cela s'est passé
n'est pas bonne en début d'émission
oui beaucoup aux femmes quand on a la
liste mois son jeu en course tout seul
avec une grande liste et serait plaît
beaucoup aux femmes elles ton regard des
femmes est souvent terminale et
recroiser dans les rayons je la croise
au yaourt serait alors croiser aux
bananes laroiseau au petit déjeuner et
petit sourire puisqu'elle voit canal à
l'illiade éveillons petit déjeuner je
sais bien sûr des bruits
et paf et les coûts matériels sur les
chantiers
[Applaudissements]
les fans excusez-moi mais chez lidl n'y
a pas de riom petit le président hu
toutes les semaines arrête de la merde
est alors allée centrale dans les
panneaux petit déjeuner sur scène mais
c'est passé pas chez lidl donc on peut
ce serait comme lui vous chez auchan
chez leclerc chez cartier et oui on va
chez lidl pas si l'édile a lâché le nom
cello notons qu'un petit déjeuner chez
moi je vais pas dire aux gens de chez
fauchon
mais c'est pas pour moi je vous pose la
question à vous aussi
est ce qu est un endroit insolite vous
avez eu un coup de foudre vous castaldi
un coup de foudre non mais une relation
dans le boeing 777
yahia l'oeil à la cabine des hôtesses
qui est au dessus la bosse non non c'est
pas la moitié de ce temps 47 ça mais et
donc c'est une idée qu'on se reposer
ouais il ya un vrai lit non et donc les
j'ai eu la chance d'aller dans cet
endroit avec un avion avec une hôtesse
dans ce lit dans ce livre et vous lui
avez montré votre c'est gratuit je vais
montrer mon secret story et c'est pas
d'ici tapez 1 et 2 et elle a bien tapé
passé avec une hôtesse grèce non bah oui
c'est confortable le père ou son cousin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
question pourquoi on s'en fout c'est
confortable on veut savoir si non c'est
une vraie chance en fait mal avec un
vrai idée donc mais attendent attendent
attendent et l'hôtesse vous la voyez
elle vous reconnaît oui et vous vous
vous je le reconnais aussi
non non vous la connaissez non je ne
connaissais pas mais on a fait
connaissance quoi combien de temps
d'avion à y avait 12 heures c'était sera
pareil de ce délai ce qui est bien peu
le temps et vous avez parlé combien de
temps avant de faire quoi alors ayez le
temps de et on vous sert le repas un
petit échange de café pousse-café machin
je le suis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui alors oui 4 rideau et donc c'est en
fait comme c'est un très long vol il ya
des rotations parce que le tome où
travaillent pas pendant tout le vol
on se repose et philippe rey j'étais me
reposer avec m voilà c'est fou et votre
femme le savez ça alors ma femme d'où
elle doit le savoir maintenant la masse
vous savez quatre femmes donc vers des
histoires pour des histoires dit qu'il a
dix à vingt ans non non ça va ça va ça
va ça va aller en forme en ce moment
très de très grande forme les dindes
regrettait alors qu'ils n'ont jamais
l'histoire
j'en ai beaucoup de rencontres insolites
mais elle elle lui fait que des
rencontres d'un sonar tgv pour aller à
lyon parce que devait monter sur scène
au guide michelin
si le guide michou tgv je vais à lyon
j'ai remonté sur scène et faire un show
et donc oui j'allais en représentation
sur ce modèle
triste la chaux de fonds ah oui ok pour
qui nos boîtes de nuit il était sur le
trottoir tgv je suis en première je lis
un bouquin arrive contre le rat ces
jeunes madame ndibu de billets je n'ai
pas une dîme donnersmarck date de
naissance pour le retrouver
il tape dates de naissance des très
beaux et me regarde et me dit je pensais
vous avez dix hommes - tellement vous
êtes beau nom mais si vous en êtes et
nuit oui je suis content je suis
contrôleur votre zizi blond magnifique
et ça comme ça et jablon vénitien non
meubles en oeuvre à 28 ans très très
beau j'en ai même petit peu plus
et du coup j bhv à lyon pour un event à
niveau et il me dit ah bon mais donc je
pense que la soirée tous à multaq l
hôtel je dis voilà mdi basse et saab est
à lyon voix des sans radio j'habite là
non plutôt que d'aller à l'hôtel un
appartement très sympathique
venez dîner à la maison et n'a cessé de
me vais me l'envoyer voulait avant la
vie vous a fait des cocktails et du coup
c'est rigolo parce qu'arriver
effectivement j'ai posé mes affaires
l'hôtel tu aller dîner chez lui et eux
pouvaient pas sortir un peu est-ce que
tu pètes alors elle répète la rosette
les ronettes elle est persuadée qu'on a
fait une bonne dont red road ma chérie
c'est pas facile il suffirait déjà les
surgériens tous les matins du coup je
aller dîner chez lui on a fait l'amour
après j'ai fait mon event est vraiment
s'il me regarde pas c'est pas une
occasion de revoir suis pas retournée à
lyon s'appelle maxime il va être content
maintenant mais il est là il va lui dire
maxime tu m'as pas me down mais j'aurais
bien aimé le revoir et puis c'est
compliqué les relations de longue
distance comme ça mais après j'ai fait
des missions et puis ça va parce que
maxime contrôleurs sncf peut envoyer un
petit mail ouais je serais ravi mais
c'était une très belle histoire session
celui de tgv bien sûr le rassure le
train à grosse verges
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très attendus comme clément éléments ou
des blancs tu as des scoops août un
lacet plein scoop mois non ça quelqu'un
est là
non non approuvés me dit clément dans
mon oreille ce conte qui a dû rencontrer
quelqu'un dans une calèche même une fois
moi c'était d'un ridicule achevé un nom
hors de sa sphère les boulistes voix
splendide jamais 10 701 room est
merveilleux et je prends une femme
perdue ce qui surprend pas les siennes
de boules mais une boule qui était
devant moi et je reste coincé par mes
bagues dans le jeu lancé la boule je
suis parti avec la boule non mais sans
blague et dans le truc de défense pour
enfants qui était vrai c'est qu'on ne
sait pas pourquoi c'est le mec qui est
venu me chercher à varna bleu rouge la
soirée ensemble mais j'étais ridicule
mal levée par le derrière en plus noté
comme ça paraît relever préfère c'est
dans la famille ridicule je crois que
c'était ma vie s'est pas couché avec
après mais non non non écouter
ces cas-là il l'aurait jamais couché
ouais bah à quoi vous vous disiez je me
couche pas bon le bac exactement génial
je couche pas avant le match j'étais
vierge pour le studio tient jean-michel
mois dans le métro soit très original la
sicafi c'est ça le centre bell et kaka
j'avais rencontré deux stations avant
c'est quoi alors à côté nous banon mais
aussi remonté il dans le métro il n'y a
pas énormément c'est en même temps juste
cinq six ans on faisait déjà la télé oui
d'accord mais ça n'a aucun rapport mais
très bien je ne sais pas mais dans le
métro c'est pas évident de trouver un
endroit puisque dans un avion c'est vrai
que j'ai déjà fait aussi on trouve
facilement arc dans le métro y a pas de
témoins on peut se cacher des caméras
partout 200 voix que j'avais trouvé si
les cabines photomaton
mais pour pas qu'on voit les pieds en
dessous on était tous les deux debout
sénat
[Rires]
y a personne que des photos arrêté
j'aurais dû mettre une pièce pour faire
une photo foutez de ma gueule non il ya
personne qui a privé le cac est ouvert
le rideau vous voyez sur les gens ne
diminuent quelqu'un qui fait des photos
que ce qui choque dans l'histoire avec
harcèlement dans le métro ça ne choque
pas du tout bah non
ah bon ça va nous faire un tp
rassemblement autour d'un terrible pénis
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien refait les logos aujourd'hui
des bienfaits du logo jourd'hui tgv en
tout cas c'est ce que c'est comme ça que
des gens vous connaissait pas au bout du
monde à mettre au travail dans ton
camion ait eu quoi il en montcalm et il
ya 15 ans moi j'ai fait ça sur les
champs elysées dans mon camion moi quoi
j'ai fait ça sur les champs elysées je
tenterai livrer une pizza arrière sur
les changes et nikki exquis et célèbre
vous livrons dizaine ont même prénom je
me suis arrêté j'étais en train de
livrer des boissons des films via madrid
joue vers le camion il en a été à
l'intérieur du camion
on est parti sur les quais ni sur nos
flux à pizza pino qu elles mêmes bien
voilà c'est tout mais pas dans les
erreurs quand tu connais pas les gens
dans le métro il marche d'un gars sont
très très beau scander avait raconté son
bras